what's up everybody
I have a crazy theory for you today that
makes a ton of sense we're going to talk
about the possibility that Galactus
could already be in the MCU I'm trying
to say that something is coming real
quick reminder about the infinity war
blu-ray giveaway if you would like to
enter all you have to do is subscribe to
my channel like this video and comment
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero so on the surface
this theory is simple
the theory is Galactus is the Power
Stone or more specifically trapped
inside of the Power Stone and that's a
pretty simple theory but then you have
to ask how in order to answer this
question you have to know a little bit
about the Infinity stones specifically
what the collector said about them and
what Oh Dan has said about them and Thor
the dark world
Odin described them as relics that
predate the universe come with me now
relics that predate the universe itself
what lies within her appears to be one
of them nine realms and not eternal
ahead adorn us then in guardians of the
galaxy the collector went into even more
detail creation itself there were six
singularity
then the universe exploded into
existence and the remnants of these
systems were forged into concentrated
ingots infinity still so before the
universe existed there were six
singularities and then the universe
exploded into existence and the remnants
of these systems were forged into
concentrated ingots Infinity stones so
the definition of a remnant is a small
remaining quantity of something so what
the collector and Odin are saying is
that before our universe existed there
were these singularities these systems
these relics that existed before and
when our universe exploded into
existence there were small remaining
pieces of these systems left and then
these pieces were forged into Infinity
stones so those are how the Infinity
stones came into existence now let's
talk about how Galactus came into
existence Galactus was once a person
named Galen Galen lived in a universe
that existed before the Big Bang so he
lived in a universe that existed before
the current MCU universe exploded into
existence
Galen lived in a technologically
advanced world called top and he became
aware that all current existing life was
about to end due to the occurrence of
the Big Bang in an attempt to save his
people he flew his spaceship into the
Big Bang's event horizon to try and stop
it from happening
but once he was inside he discovered a
cosmic entity called the sentience of
the universe he ended up merging with
the sentience of the universe as the Big
Bang decimated his universe he was then
resurrected in the new universe and
drifted alone in an inert state for
billions of years this is how Galactus
came to be now being a life-form of pure
energy
so Galactus existed before the current
universe exploded into existence when
his universe was decimated he was the
only thing left or the only remnant left
of that universe now existing in the
current universe being a life form of
pure energy this lines up exactly with
what Odin and the collector said they
said that there were these singularities
these systems
these relics that existed before their
universe and then their universe
exploded into existence essentially a
Big Bang and there were remnants of
these systems leftover one of them being
Galactus now this of course is where you
have to realize that the MCU is
different from the comics but they do
however pull ideas from the comics and
the comics Galactus is found and awoken
by the watcher he then becomes Galactus
devourer of worlds destroying world
after world believing himself a superior
being that is responsible for keeping
the balance between death and eternity
so let's compare Galactus who literally
feeds off of planets by destroying them
being a life form of pure raw energy to
the Power Stone for starters the obvious
one it's purple Galactus is purple it's
blue we're blue it's just important okay
trust us but really in ancient times the
Celestials use the Power Stone to judge
and destroy worlds the Power Stone
destroying worlds Galactus devourer of
worlds it's all starting to click not to
mention that the scene that the
collector shows us of the celestial
being judging and destroying a world the
staff that the celestial being keeps the
Power Stone in it looks an awful lot
like Galactus his helmet this lines up
way too much to be coincidental but to
wrap it all up the collector says that
these remnants were forged into Infinity
stones perhaps this means that these
remnants that were left over from past
universes were extremely powerful beings
and somebody who was afraid of their
power imprisoned them and trapped them
in or turned them into an infinity stone
and who could have done that perhaps it
was the watcher again the MCU is not
exactly like the comics but they do draw
ideas from the comics and in the comics
The Watcher is the person who finds
Galactus and the watcher does exist in
the MCU whether or not we've seen him
because we don't really know what he
looks like he does exist we know this
because in guardians of the galaxy to
Stan Lee's character description was
watcher informant so we know the watcher
exists and it's very possible that he
could
be responsible for forging the Infinity
stones this all seems to line up way too
perfectly to be a coincidence everything
from being before the universe exploded
into existence being a remnant of the
previous universe being the color purple
such as the Power Stone is and the staff
looking exactly like Galactus helmet it
all lines up and points to Galactus
being stuck inside the Power Stone that
is my belief I think this theory makes
so much sense but what do you all think
about it I want to know so let me know
your thoughts in the comments and again
the infinity war blu-ray giveaway
continues all you have to do to enter is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment below with your thoughts and
your favorite superhero thank you so
much for watching woof woof
[Music]